nous allons maintenant à cannes où le
palmarès du festival a été proclamé il
ya un petit peu plus de deux heures
seulement la palme d'or va à the tree of
life l'arbre de vie de terrence malick
et jean dujardin reçoit le prix
d'interprétation masculine il était en
concurrence avec brad pitt et sean penn
entre autres à cannes
nathalie et terre et jean jacques botti
c'était le film le plus attendu cette
année sur la croisette
les femmes de terrence malick ne seront
donc pas déçus tatoué of life l'arbre de
vie palme d'or 2011
le jury a ainsi récompensé le
réalisateur qui à force de ne jamais se
montrer est devenu une légende
brad pitt en père très autoritaire dans
l'amérique des années 50 avec shawn penn
dans le rôle du fils devenu grand et
toute une réflexion presque
philosophique sur l'origine du monde
2h15 d'image sublime mais qui ne
trouveront pas forcément un large public
terrence malick une fois de plus étaient
absents mais apparemment heureux selon
son producteur qui a reçu la palme à sa
place et remis à jean dujardin un prix
largement méritée pour le comédien
français qui dans le film the artist
incarne une star du cinéma muet un
véritable rôle de composition sans un
mot prononcé le tout en noir et blanc
je vais partager ce prix avec bérénice
bejo sa partenaire
ce fut une surprise car c'est une autre
que l'on attendait personnes dont ce
meilleur actrice dans le film
melancholia de lars von trier une
récompense symbolique qui a sans doute
voulu prouver que l'on se devait de
distinguer l'oeuvre de l'artiste
rappelons que lars von triera été
expulsé du festival pour des propos très
déplacés sur hitler
et puis l'émotion de maïwenn prix du
jury pour son film polisse y suit le
quotidien de la brigade de protection
des mineurs
de l'avis de tous ce cru 2011 aura été
d'une qualité exceptionnelle
rendez vous donc sur la croisette
l'année prochaine